[Música]
la vida está llena de pequeñas paredes y
de grandes murallas y es nuestra
decisión y solamente nuestra quedarnos
mirando las pasar sobre ellas
soy abraham cohen y es aproximadamente
dos años
a mí me detectaron cáncer para ser
exactos esto fue el informe de hodgkin y
para los que no saben qué es esto que
seguramente es la mayoría de ustedes
esto es en los ganglios adonde viven las
defensas las que nos defienden de
cualquier enfermedad cuando el doctor y
mis papás me dieron la noticia se me
presentó un enorme muralla que sabía que
iba a cambiar mi vida de un momento a
otro mi cabeza comenzó a viajar millones
de kilómetros imagínense todas las cosas
que me podían pasar mi doctor me frenó
en seco y me explicó de forma muy
detallada a que me enfrentar y cómo iba
a ser mi tratamiento yo también comencé
a investigar un poco sobre todo sobre el
tipo de cáncer que a mí me dio
de un momento a otro todo mi miedo se
transformó en fuerza y así vino la
primera lección que me dejó el cáncer
que fue que para cualquier reto lo
primero que debemos hacer es informarnos
prepararnos y conocer a lo que nos vamos
a enfrentar después vino una muralla más
está mucho más grande y mucho más
difícil de vencer y fueron los
tratamientos a los que me tenía que
someter para poder superar esta
enfermedad tenía que estar una noche en
el hospital cada dos semanas y las
medicinas que me daban me hacían sentir
fatal me daban muchísimas nauseas me
hacían vomitar todo el día y me dejaban
totalmente agotado por dos o tres días
más esta muralla la tuve que aprender a
vencer con mucha actitud y mucha
terminación y tuve que aprender a ser
fuerte ante esta situación quien se
inspiró levanten la mano bueno todos
ustedes que levantaron la mano recuerden
este momento para que justamente
saliendo de aquí puedan ir a cumplir
todo lo que se les plazca a mí todo esto
me llevó a pensar y porque yo no si
ellos que tuvieron problemas peores
pudieron luchar en contra de todas sus
limitaciones quedó que me tenía a mí así
que comencé a ponerme metas la primera
de ellas fue completar un triatlón
hice mi primer triatlón en marzo el año
pasado aquí me veo bien
hasta podemos decir que me vio un poco
confiado bueno en verdad fue mucho más
difícil de lo que pensé busquen yo en el
de la gorra negra yo soy de los más
chiquitos de ahí al empezar el triatlón
yo tenía que ver a todos así imaginen si
el miedo antes de empezar cualquier cosa
aquí yo estaba saliendo la natación se
puede ver el sufrimiento en mis ojos y
aquí empezando la bici casi casi me
estaba peleando el último lugar con este
otro niño
los triatlones fueron mucho más difícil
lo que pensé casi me ahogo en la etapa
de natación se me salió la cadena de la
bici lo bueno fue que la carrera me fue
bien yo creo que lo lógico hubiera sido
pensar que los triatlones no eran para
mí pero una vez más decidí ponerme las
pilas y entrenar duro y pasar esta
muralla en mi primer triatlón que entre
los últimos lugares por después de
entrenar duro en el último que participe
quedé entre los 10 mejores y voy por mi
siguiente en octubre en cozumel el
cáncer me dio las herramientas y me dio
una excusa para superar cualquier otro
reto
cada vez que yo me enfrento tu reto me
digo a mí mismo si ya pude con esta
enfermedad que me tiene para superar
cualquier otro reto así que buscan algo
grande que hayan superado y usen una
referencia porque mientras más grande la
muralla más grande se logró cuando hice
cosas que la gente no esperaba me vi
como esto era como una droga cada vez
que hacía una quería otra y otra
empiecen con algo chico iban a ver cómo
lo van a poder parar y así van a
inspirar a más gente y esta gente va a
poder inspirar a más gente
ahora quiero contarles una historia en
enero tuve la oportunidad de irme eeuu
una semana a estudiar a una escuela y en
la primera clase el maestro dijo algo
que cambió mi forma de pensar él dijo
algo así me wrong as fast as you can y a
lo que se refiere este dicho es el que
no se equivoca no aprende y el que no
aprende no se supera a sí hay que perder
el miedo a equivocarse y hay que empezar
a superarse si te caes te paras y si te
acaba no no yo entré en descargas
cierra los ojos todos y piensen cuántas
veces han tratado algo pero no les sale
pero han vuelto a tratar hasta que le
sale puede ser con cualquier cosa con la
persona que quieren con el examen que
reprobaron con lo que sea tómense ese
tiempo
ya
ok vamos aprecio mucho no quiero que me
digan pero si contaron entre cinco
intentos o más van en buen camino si
contaron entre cero y cuatro intentos no
dejen que sus miedos y sus errores los
definan aprende de ellos pero no vivas
en el pasado y para acabar quisiera
decirles que la inspiración es pasión no
van a llegar tocando sus puertas los
primeros que deben de querer deben ser
ustedes porque ni el mejor speech de la
persona más inspiradora del mundo los va
a poder ayudar aunque ojalá este les
sirva
ahora los quiero dejar con unas palabras
de zig ziglar
si jartúm innings porque no verificaron
por face sobre tim white the choice is
yours